here's how Sydney [ __ ] put it when he
was asked what makes a great casting
director there's a coming together of
abilities that raise this job into an
art form
the ability to immediately skip the
expected the cliche the ability to
understand the inner life of a script or
a scene or a moment of behavior between
two people and most of all the ability
to somehow imagine the chemical
reactions possible when the personality
of a specific actor rubs against in an
unexpected way the personality of the
character on the page that is the art of
Lynn Stoll master
here are some of the filmmakers who
relied on Lin's keen eye and
extraordinary instinct for acting talent
Billy Wilder George Stevens Robert waz
Stanley Kramer William Wyler Norman
Jewison how Ashby Blake Edwards John
Cassavetes Mike Nichols and Sydney
[ __ ] and the Academy is honoured
actors from films cast by Lynne with 36
Oscar nominations and 11 Oscar wins on a
more
on a more personal note 34 years ago Lin
heard about my casting work in New York
he hired me and moved me to Los Angeles
to be his associate and he has been my
mentor ever since so many lessons
learned from this glorious man but
mostly Lin taught me by example that
being a success in Hollywood and being a
mensch are not mutually exclusive I love
you Lin I don't know if Oprah Winfrey's
in the house but this is what she would
call a full circle moment on behalf of
my fellow governor's Laura Kennedy and
Bernie Chelsea and the entire casting
directors branch we salute you as a
pioneer we thank you for setting the bar
high and to the first casting director
in the history of the Academy to receive
an Oscar we say congratulations